[Music]
morning all we begin with breaking news
that's due on the cost of living crisis
uh let's speak now to our business
correspondent helen ann smith who's at
our royal mail sorting center in east
london this morning helen and as we
await that data i mean you might as well
explain this isn't a career change for
you is it
it's not a career change for me but it's
really really interesting to see what
goes on at a royal mail
sorting center but we're here to talk
about wages uh to talk about the
employment data in the economy we get a
big dump uh this morning it tells us all
sorts of things about unemployment
employment figures and all the rest of
it but the thing we're really interested
in is wages and particularly wages in
terms of how they keep up uh with
inflation and we just have had the
figure
drop so in the three months of the
quarter the three months april to june
compared to what it was last year in
real terms uh workers wages fell by
three percent so what that essentially
means is when you compare it to
inflation uh in the real terms in terms
of how we feel in our in our everyday
lives wages going down by three percent
and worth saying actually that that's
compared to a specific measure of
inflation that actually includes things
like housing and stuff so actually
doesn't really affect your day-to-day uh
sort of budget if you like so actually
once we have a bit more time and go
through the data in a bit more detail
we'll try and get you that figure for
what essentially in your day-to-day
living without housing how it would uh
feel but look it's bad news for workers
of course it is this is the seventh
month in a row
that workers wages have fallen in real
time and it means that workers across
the economy are facing extremely
difficult times at the moment as i said
i'm in a rural mail sorting office uh
fascinating to see what's going on here
uh these are the packages um that are
being sorted in the sort of
old-fashioned manual way if we swing
around there's actually some training
going on and a brand new machine that
would automate the sort of the
processing of those packages around
seven thousand an hour uh this machine
can process and it matters because
workers at royal mail are one of just
many groups across the economy who have
validated to strike because they say
that their pay is not keeping up with
that inflation royal mail say that
they've offered a very generous package
5.5 percent linked to productivity but
the union at the moment have rejected
that but it's worth saying that it just
shows doesn't it
just the discontent across workers
across the economy because it's not just
here at royal mail it's in the trains uh
network rail uh in the tubes uh nurses
are thinking about balloting to strike
so our teachers so our criminal
barristers in all these different
sectors workers finding the cost of
living at the moment just very very
difficult to keep up with
helena and we'll give you the
opportunity to sort through the data see
what i did there we'll speak to you
again soon thanks very much for now
let's talk about the weather shall we
and after weeks of dry baking hot
conditions much of the uk is today
covered by warnings of flash flooding
and thunderstorms three med office
weather warnings are in fact in effect
this morning that includes a yellow
weather warning for thunderscrolls
across most of the uk
we're being told that the conditions
could cause flash flooding disruption to
transport
and possibly power cuts that warning
will stay in place tomorrow for some
areas including the east midlands east
of england london and southeast england
south west england and the west midlands
a separate yellow weather warning for
rain has been issued for southern and
eastern scotland that warning staying in
place until at least 10 o'clock this
morning
well these are some of the latest
pictures that we have from trudeau in
cornwall where heavy rain soon led to
widespread flooding yesterday afternoon
one eyewitness said the water level was
the highest he's ever seen in the county
well the flooding also made its mark
across the border in devon this is one
of the buildings at the milky way
adventure theme park a popular resort
especially during the summer holidays
staff worked after hours to mop up the
mess and luckily the park set to open
today
similar scene in parts of scotland too
this footage was taken in colonic in
east airship where it's reported that
police were forced to shut certain roads
and parts of ireland have also been
affected by the flooding uh drivers were
urged to be extra cautious
as the roads were inundated in a number
of areas including new ross in county
wexford
things didn't get much better as it
started to get dark fire engines had to
be deployed to help these two vehicles
in county carl
and you keep sending us your pictures of
the weather where you are
but now three british men accused of
being mercenaries fighting with
ukrainian forces against russia have
pleaded not guilty in a court
administered by kremlin back separatists
in the donetsk people's republic
uh let's speak to our correspondent ali
bunkel who is in odessa forest this
morning ali good to see you and just
explain exactly what is going on here
significant concerns about these three
brits not least because they could be
facing a death penalty
yeah the russians if they capture any
foreign fighters or people who they
believe are foreign fighters um they are
putting them on trial in some of the
areas that they currently occupy and
this trial having the what's known as
the donetsk people republic by the
russians but it is still officially a
part of ukraine and a part of ukraine
that kiev hopes to recapture in due
course these three britons john harding
andrew hill
dylan healey um all captured in
different places and doing different
things for example dylan healy was an
aid worker
john harding was captured around the
city of mariupol but they're all accused
of being mercenaries by the russians and
they've all pleaded not guilty to that
so they will be back in court in october
now the british government uh has very
uh fiercely reacted to any kind of
trials of this kind of british nationals
saying that they're show trials and
saying that people should be treated as
prisoners of war under the geneva
convention and not put on trial and
potentially sentenced to death so a very
serious situation potentially awaiting
those three britons elsewhere uh the
fighting continues uh in every bit as a
brutal manner as it has been for almost
the last uh six months the focus uh is
around here in the southern front and
perhaps uh potential counter-offensive
on the city of hassan uh but also
europe's largest nuclear power plant at
zaparisia currently occupied by the
russians but has been shelled a number
of times in the recent days and weeks
the russians blame the ukrainians the
ukrainians blame the russians but the
united nations and others around the
world are saying given that it is a
nuclear power plant it is a very very
worrying situation indeed and they need
the firing to stop around there so that
inspectors can get in and make sure that
it's safe
alec many thanks indeed
now you may well have noticed that we
are exactly three weeks away from either
liz truss or rishi sunak entering
downing street but tonight they'll head
to path for the seventh tory leadership
hustings event and the only one to be
held in scotland the conservative mp for
west aberdeenshire and kincardine andrew
bowie joins us now and he's supporting
rishi sunak mr bowie great to have you
on the programme this morning uh rishi
sunak heading north to take pla to take
part in the hustings we keep our fingers
crossed that he doesn't end up in
darlington instead of path what is his
offer to the scottish people
well look uh rookie is uh is
quite clearly the most capable most
competent person to hold this uh country
together to maintain scotland's place at
the heart of our united kingdom as a
part of what he's offering he's going to
be making scottish civil servants and
the scottish government more accountable
uh to the uk parliament that will
involve asking scottish government civil
servants to be more present
in front of uk government uk parliament
committees sorry so that we can hold the
scottish government to account their
spending decisions their performance in
areas of health and education so many
areas that the scottish people uh
complain that the scottish government
are not delivering for them but at the
same time we're going to be making uk
government ministers more accountable to
the scottish parliament making sure that
they are more visible and they attend
scottish parliamentary committees
more often but at the end of the day now
you know whoever wins this leadership
election scotland's place at the heart
of this united kingdom will always be
the front and center for conservative
unionist party leaders uh pitch we are
the only party that's standing front and
center to ensure scotland's place at the
heart of our united kingdom and we look
forward to taking that argument to the
country
with respect
is that it increased scrutiny of the
scottish government i mean if that is
your pitch for maintaining the union i'm
going to gently suggest you might need
to do a little bit more than that
well no i mean the other arguments uh
stand alone no matter who is actually
our leader uh you know scotland's
economic prosperity scotland security uh
scotland's place on the world stage all
of that uh will be assured by scotland
remaining apart by united kingdom and
all of that would stand through no
matter who wins this leadership election
what we're talking about today is what
richie sunak would do if he became prime
minister and how he would hold the
scottish government uh more to count
i've lost trust as things stand mister
as things stand it's not going to be
rishi sunak who's the next prime
minister is it on the basis of the
polling that we have seen and indeed
another defection overnight uh to this
trustee's team alan kearns uh switching
from rishi tsunak to liz trust simply
because he believes that the foreign
secretary uh not the former chancellor
is the best person to save the union
look i mean you said yourself we've
still got three weeks of this contest
look forward to i know you can't contain
your excitement we've still got many
hustings uh across the united kingdom
we've got one in perth uh this evening i
look forward to seeing rishi up here in
the northeast of scotland aberdeenshire
later on this morning we'll be taking
our case to conservative party members
north of the border and we've got a long
way to run so i wouldn't pay too much
attention supposedly i'm a scottish
conservative if i'd paid any attention
to polls and i wouldn't be sitting here
at all neil so the fact is that we've
got a long way to run we've got
many thousands of party members still to
speak to and i'd recommend this very
much in contention to be the next leader
of this uh party next video of this
country and that's what i'm working very
much to to making sure happens
as you will of course be aware i mean
there are still large parts of scotland
which are are incredibly deprived there
were reports just a few days ago that mr
sunak has just spent 400 000 pounds on a
swimming pool i mean genuinely is there
not a part of you that is perhaps in
any way concerned that someone who's
richer than crisis could be given the
controls the macroeconomic controls
that being prime minister comes with
that come with being prime minister
look i'm not in politics the politics of
envy i actually believe in the politics
of aspiration i think if somebody is
successful i think there's a genuine
question to be asked when someone has
600 700 800 million pounds in the bank
about whether or not there are perhaps
concerns
about them being given the controls the
levers of the levers to the economy well
if you're talking about whether rishi
sooner can uh
understand the problems in the situation
facing many thousands many millions of
people in the country of course he can
this is the man who saved 11 million
jobs by creating the furlough escape
this is the man who saved businesses
from going under with the bounce back
loan scheme and other things that he
produced during the pandemic this is the
man who introduced etac to help out to
ensure that people working in
hospitality had jobs to go to this this
is also the man
this is also the man that ensured that
the bp and shell didn't pay any tax on
north sea oil
now this is the man that introduced the
energy profits levy uh just recently
increasing the tax
on north sea oil and gas production at
the same time as incentivizing further
development of north sea oil and gas
because what we need to do is get to a
place where we're energy secure energy
self-sufficient so that in the long run
we don't face the same problems uh in
our energy supply as we are facing
right now so to claim that he didn't
introduce any tax
on oil and gas uh it's expansible
frankly they were already paying 45
uh tax on their uh profits ahead of the
energy profits levy which the russia
sunac introduced rishi has introduced
many forms of taxation on the oil and
gas industry to ensure that they pay
their their way and pay their fair share
towards the british people who are
struggling at this time and in what he
has done he was also
responsible for the 600 700 million
pounds that bp and rochelle received
from the government this is this is the
situation we have at the moment we have
energy companies making record profits
we have them not paying any tax on north
sea oil extraction we have people who
cannot pay their energy bills i would
just like someone in the conservative
party at the moment to concede that the
market has failed this is a complete
failure of the market
now it's completely not true to suggest
that the oil and gas sector are not
paying tax they are paying their fair
share of tax in fact they're paying more
intact than ever before thanks to what
richie sunak introduced as a part of the
energy profits levy but the fact is we
need to incentivize and improve and
increase oil and gas production in the
north sea if we aren't going to be
further relying on people like vladimir
putin for our energy supply if we are
going to be energy secure and energy
self-sufficient in the future which will
help drive down prices and make sure we
aren't left at the mercy of fluctuations
in the worldwide energy supply i'm
sitting here talking to you from
aberdeen in the north east of scotland
and i know now i don't need to tell you
how important to this region's economy
the oil and gas sector is and that's why
we've got to get it right we're going to
tax them what they are owed and they are
being taxed and we've got to incentivize
further investment in the north sea we
are both doing both those things and
rishi senate as chancellor ensured that
we got the balance right between
incentivization and taxation and that's
what we're doing right now
my my point is simply that there seems
to be a pattern of behaviour when it
comes to mr sunac and tax now we know in
terms of his family finances that he's
been keen to limit his exposure but what
about amazon thanks to the super
deduction scheme they will be paying
little or no tax for another two years
and all of this infrastructure spending
that they have been doing on new
warehouses which they would almost
certainly have done without the
government choosing to subsidise it
we're paying for it that's because of
the former chancellor
i'm sorry i can't accept what you just
said about rishi sunak limiting his
exposure tax which she said like has
paid every penny that he has owed to the
uk exchequer he has always been a
british taxpayer and remains a british
taxpayer should put that to one side in
terms of the super deduction
every option sorry
i said we can put the non-dom thing to
one side if you prefer
look his wife paid his wife now p's and
it has now paid back every penny of
taxes she was owed and rishi himself has
always been a uk taxpayer and has paid
every penny of tax that he's owed to the
uk exchequer so he's not limited his
exposure i think that's fanciful and i
think we should put that to one side and
in terms of what we're doing we're
taxing british companies they're fair
share we're making sure they invest in
the future of this country we're
improving and increasing international
investment in this country to ensure
that we get the investment right we
build the infrastructure that's needed
and we move to a high-tech low-tax
high-skilled economy that i know that we
all want to see that's what rishi
sanak's plan is if he became prime
minister that's what he was driving
towards he was chancellor and that's
what i think he would deliver if he wins
his leadership contest
does does rishi sunak think that
nicholas sturgeon is an attention seeker
i think uh you could judge nicholas
sturgeon by her own actions the uh twice
vogue uh cover star uh nicola sturgeon
uh whether or not she would claim that
she was an attention seeker at all the
fact the problem the thing about what
liz pruss said in exeter isn't that
nicholas she claimed nicola was an
attention seeker it's that we ignore the
snp now we don't beat the snp by
ignoring them we beat the snp by taking
them on at the ballot box and winning
the argument and that's what i want to
see and that's what richie sunic would
do if he became leader of the
conservative party
mr barry i know aberdeen very well
indeed in fact my uncle and family stay
up that way beautiful part of the world
er thanks very much for joining us take
care
thank you very much
and ahead of the tory hustings roadshow
heading to scotland for the one and only
time in the campaign we'll be hearing
from the snp's westminster leader ian
blackford in just over an hour's time
let's take a quick look through some of
the papers uh we'll start with the
mirror that tells the story of tammy
prescott a terminally ill mother who
says energy bills means she can't afford
to properly enjoy her final days with
her two young daughters
the eye has worn that a next generation
covered vaccine will be rolled out in
the autumn specifically designed to
tackle the damaging omicron variant
now from scotland the national carries a
poll which found that well no matter who
becomes the next prime minister support
for independence will likely increase
meanwhile the guardian hears that why
all civil servants could strike after
they learned of plans to cut their
payoffs in the event of redundancy
the metro reports on the rape trial rate
trial of manchester city footballer
benjamin mendy he denies the charges
against him
the telegraph says the royal navy is
planning to end its role in combating
the influx of migrants crossing the
channel
while the mail leads with the prospect
of more airport chaos at the next half
town
after heathrow extended its cap on the
number of passengers and flights it can
handle
and according to the financial times
china has cut one of its key landing
rates in an attempt to soften the
economic blow
of the pandem
as you can see tamara cohen uh joins us
once again the studio morning tc um well
let's talk about the conservative uh
battle of course just speaking will not
go to andrew andrew barry
member of team sunak um i mean it's not
looking good for them although you have
to say the polls have started to narrow
that's right and if you look at that
poll from the national about how they're
doing in scotland they've both got a lot
of ground to make up in scotland um
scottish conservatives were largely more
against boris johnson than conservatives
were in england a lot of scottish mps
were at the forefront of suggesting that
boris johnson should resign um they want
somebody who they can put their trust in
and at the moment both richie cena and
liz trust are talking a lot about
wanting to oppose another independence
referendum wanting to hold the scottish
government to account more but they've
got and they've got both got ideas on
that front about how to make sure the
scottish government publishes data or
gets civil servants to account for their
decisions but certainly they have to win
people over when they go up there and
take members questions and show they get
the tone right so that's going to be the
job that they have to do tonight and the
suggestions are that whoever wins
support for independence may well
increase off the back of it
they will need to secure some votes from
scottish conservatives tonight but of
course the big question at that hustings
and in every hustings is of course the
cost of living and what they're going to
do about it and um
there's a real deafening silence i
thought from many conservatives about
kierstama's big policy yesterday they
have largely
yes suggested that it may not work but
not really gone for it particularly and
i think that's because both of the
contenders are under pressure to
announce something that would really
rise to the scale of the challenge we're
not suggesting they're going to neck
well i think that the both of them are
very opposed to the idea of extending
the windfall tax and you do wonder
whether that is going to hold given the
popularity um in polls of the idea that
energy companies need to pay a bit more
so that the rest of us pay a bit less so
they're against it for now but i think
they see the risks of really going for
something which will give people a
thousand pounds in their pockets
whatever the questions and there are
plenty of questions about how expensive
it is tomorrow for now thanks very much
indeed
plenty more still to come on the program
a year on since the taliban returned to
power in afghanistan
i'll be speaking with the head of the
norwegian refugee council about what the
last 12 months have been like
for the people that live there
[Music]
and after labour leader secure starmer
unveiled his party's plans to tackle the
cost of living crisis i'm going to be
joined in the studio by the shadow
climate change secretary ed miliband
we're looking forward to this one i'll
be speaking to a bubble business owner
about her concerns about the cost of
living and indeed how it will affect her
livelihood
[Music]
well i'm just back from my holidays i
wonder if any of you are going to be
heading off perhaps even heading off via
heathrow a bit of news this morning
about
potential problems come the next half
term uh we're joined now by sabatry who
is indeed down at the airport at sabah
what are you hearing
good morning neil well agony for parents
who may have had some holidays planned
for the half term period coming up in
october and that's because heathrow
airport have extended their flight cap
it initially was running from just for
the summer period they introduced it in
july and that was until uh september the
11th but they've now moved that date to
october the 29th now the airport is
saying that this is because what they're
doing at the moment is working there
have been significantly less last-minute
flight uh cancellations there have been
less issues with things like baggage and
for this reason they have moved at the
date now this of course comes after
months of severe issues and travel
disruption within the aviation sector
and it's something that for a while now
has been going on and we're being told
is not going away at just yet now this
comes
as their the airline industry phases out
of covid restrictions uh amongst
many
staff shortages now i was on the british
airways website not that long ago and i
saw that they were offering a 1 000
sign-on bonus for some roles relating to
ground operation staff which is telling
of the situation at the moment now this
cap is constantly in review they're
saying and they want to lift it but they
only will once they are confident that
they can offer uh passengers a
successful flying experience
sabbah many thanks indeed
now let's bring some today's other news
when we start in the united states where
donald trump
has accused the fbi of stealing three
passports during their search of his
mar-a-lago estate the fbi raided the
former u.s president's home when
officials discovered boxes containing
classified information were taken after
his presidency came to an end
a department of justice official has
told nbc news that passports belonging
to mr trump are not in the possession of
the fbi and have been returned
and donald trump's former attorney rudy
giuliani is a target of the criminal
investigation in georgia that has been
examining efforts to overturn the
results of the 2020 presidential
election the move to designate giuliani
as a target as opposed to a subject
confirms his identification as a key
figure in the attempt to reverse the
former president's electoral defeat to
joe biden in the state
a british teenager has died while on
holiday in turkey the 14 year old boy
reportedly got into difficulty while
swimming at a hote hotel near antar
antalya on sunday afternoon the
spokesman for the foreign office says
they're supporting his family and are in
contact with local authorities
u.s rapper asap rocky has been charged
with two counts of assault with a
firearm in los angeles the musician
allegedly aimed a handgun and fired it
at someone in november last year
rocky who recently had a baby with
singer rihanna is due to appear in court
tomorrow where he's expected to enter a
plea
to kenya where deputy president william
ruto has been declared the winner of the
presidential election amidst as you can
see scuffles and indeed allegations of
vote ringing he narrowly beat his rival
taking 50.5
of the vote according to the official
results sky's africa correspondent yusra
albania spoke with him shortly after the
announcement
how will you respond to a contested
election outcome
um
this election
to the best of our knowledge and
understanding
is over
we are a democratic country
we have built robust
institutions
that
can
uh
undertake
the resolution of any issue
over 1 billion barbie dolls have been
sold since she first hit the shelves in
1959 but now the first ever doll with
hearing aids is joining the lineup
well she's been launched by strictly
champion rose ailing ellis who's been
deaf since birth she says she used to
draw her hearing aids on her dogs when
she was little adding that she was
thrilled that kids can celebrate and
embrace their differences with the new
range other additions include the first
ken gall with the kendall with the
schito with skin condition one with a
prosthetic limb and another in a
wheelchair
uh well let's return to the weather
emerging across the uk sky middle
meteorologist joel robinson joins us now
joe lovely to see you not raining where
you are but rain's definitely on the way
it certainly is yes it's currently not
raining here at the moment but for
england and wales we'll see widespread
thunderstorms developing today rain over
southern eastern scotland too but dry
conditions for ireland and northern
ireland let's take a look at the details
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so today we're going to see
thunderstorms developing we're currently
seeing thunderstorms across the channel
at the moment they will spread
northwards and as the morning progresses
and the heat builds we will see further
thunderstorms developing across england
and wales some heavy rain across
southern and eastern parts of scotland
this morning but that rain will ease as
we go through the course of the morning
and dry conditions across thailand and
northern ireland so temperatures for
this afternoon we will see a high of
around 26 or 27 degrees celsius in the
south and it's muggy too across much of
england and wales and that's why we're
seeing those thunderstorms developing
and they will bring some torrential rain
torrential downpours could bring travel
disruption and local flash flooding
so
tricky conditions across england and
wales and we will see the focus of those
storms across lincolnshire to the south
west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh well clearly with parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
including the united kingdom let's take
a quick look at the impact of climate
change on the planet now the right half
of the screen shows how the uk's power
is currently being produced none of it
coming from coal at the moment but a
significant proportion 56
uh coming from gas on the top left you
can see just how much warmer the earth
is now than back in 1880 when records
began at
1.26 degrees celsius warmer in fact and
finally bottom left the total amount of
co2 emissions in tons
uh now bit of a change of direction
today marks 45 years since the world
said goodbye to the king
of rock and roll
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah you just saw elvis in there a
little bit uh it is now nearly half a
century since we lost the legend uh that
was elvis presley and of course people
will be marking the anniversary of his
death today
and indeed throughout what's known as
elvis week but some already have
overnight fans gathered at graceland
to attend an annual candlelit vigil in
the singer's memory and there will no
doubt be further tributes to come
throughout the day including from me
cracking some suspicious minds anyway
welcome back the people of afghanistan
are facing a serious economic and
humanitarian crisis
but on monday the taliban supporters
took to the streets to celebrate an
official national holiday it is of
course one year since the taliban
regained control of the country and
perhaps the most significant thing to
happen excuse me is its decision to stop
women from receiving higher education a
senior taliban official has told sky
news that should not be a reason for the
international community to cut aid but
asked for more time to make changes
skies stewart ramsey reports again from
kabul as the taliban celebrates a
national
to holiday of muslim people that is a
very happy day a year ago they said they
couldn't believe they took kabul so
easily they celebrated then and they
still are
on a now public holiday the taliban took
to the streets in their famous pickup
trucks and of course now in their
captured cars
to this conquering army nato's greatest
failure was never in doubt
they say they always knew
these enormous convoys have been going
on continuously as you can see they're
all still fully armed i think what the
message from the taliban to the outside
world is we're here we're still armed
and we're here to stay
[Music]
exactly a year on the taliban continued
a new tradition of a televised media
event open to the international media
but overwhelmingly attended by loyalists
special forces soldiers struggle to hold
back people eager to get inside
and seems somewhat at a loss what to do
with women
in the audience taliban royalty
including anas hakani a powerful 28 year
old leader and negotiator with the
united states in doha
his arrival sparked a flurry of activity
by the press corps eager for pictures of
him by chance he sat behind me and we
started chatting
he told me economically afghanistan is
struggling because foreign aid has been
slashed and assets frozen
the key sticking point with the
international community is education for
girls
in his interview with sky news he hinted
at compromise but explained it would
take time to convince the taliban's old
guard saying the world must give him
some room
ultra conservative group this is a big
deal
how the world deals with the taliban in
the future is undecided of course
for the foot soldiers celebrating
outside the now mothballed american
embassy a symbol of a failed campaign to
change afghanistan
none of this really matters right now
in truth many of these taliban were
babies when the war started
a trillion dollars and 21 years later
they're in total control
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
jan egeland is the secretary general of
the norwegian refugee council and joins
us now jan great to see you um you saw
or you perhaps heard an in stewart's
report the taliban celebrating a year
since they they took kabul and the
country i suspect though that ordinary
afghans don't have very much to
celebrate what what is your appraisal of
just how dire the humanitarian situation
is there right now
well it couldn't have been worse
and still it is going to be a free fall
further down this winter
unless
the western countries that
ran uh for cover in uh
exactly one year ago and left 40 million
civilian africans behind
unless
the the west is having a renewed
dialogue with the taliban to try to
restore the economy there has been a
total collapse in the in the economy of
afghanistan it was dire before so even
though there is less fighting
there is more access to communities that
we the aid workers can reach now we
couldn't during the yes or war
there is no income and people are
starving
through stewart's reporting yesterday we
saw just how catastrophic the situation
was particularly in the hospitals the
the norwegian refugee council themselves
have seen on the ground you know babies
dying people starving and yet
the west doesn't seem particularly
minded to as you put it to to work with
the taliban
no
and of course the taliban won a bitter
war but they were it for 20 years given
expectations
hopes promises to the women the girls
the civilians of afghanistan and they
are still there so
what we hope what we beg for is that
there is renewed
contact
both sides
have to reach out to the other because
this
afghanistan lived on development date
before they they lived on subsidies they
lived on world bank
now that world bank money is frozen
development assistance is taken back the
banking system has been paralyzed
because of the sanctions there is no
printing of bank notes so indeed the
taliban has a lot of goals and they have
a lot on their conscience including
crushing hopes for an entire generation
of afghan girls
but it is as much the western sanctions
that is now holding back
some
degree of economic uh recovery
and it also holding back uh you know
food production and so on that is needed
before this harsh winter that is coming
we have 1400 aid workers on the ground
we are now struggling in in in a
hopeless situation between a a tough and
difficult and
discriminatory regime and on this other
side
the outside world which does cut and run
and is not
interested in afghanistan anymore it
seems
yeah that's that is a significant number
of people that the refugee council has
working there i mean to what extent are
the taliban allowing you to do your job
well we have access to the corners of
the country which we couldn't go before
because there was crossfire there there
was we were attacked there so that's the
good news of course in the in the
countryside where there was no hope even
before
listen in many areas there was no
education there was no services there
was only war
now the whole country's in is engulfed
in this economic uh
misery but at least we can operate now
in many many
corners of the world we have three 400
female
staff
whom we try to promote whom we whom we
we do not just discriminate against on
the other hand we try to promote their
careers of course they also have
problems now with the taliban being
having this medivh medieval
you know
relationship
to gender equality
just in terms of the way in which the
taliban operate um yesterday i spoke to
michael keating former u.n deputy envoy
to afghanistan
he he claimed that the taliban is
experiencing what a degree of infighting
between you know the 2001 taliban and
i hate to use this phrase but the rather
more progressive members of the taliban
yeah i i think there is uh
very different
lines of thought there and of course i
am among those who are really
disappointed that
these bearded men to our face when i
went to kabul last autumn said
there will be girls education
we will open up there will be a
protection of human rights there will be
full minority protection there will be
no discrimination and then
girls tried to get back to secondary
school to higher education and they were
denied they have now been confined to
homes
that is a
breach of the word really those who
dealt with us in kabul there are other
people sitting in kandahar who seems now
to call the shot which again calls for
engagement if if western diplomats now
are only interested in in ukraine uh and
a few other places and being very
nationalistic
in their attitude
then
we have failed forever these
20 million women who got all of these
hopes and who are now now actually
thinking of how can we survive this
winter perhaps even more than how can we
get back to school
jan eggerland secretary general of the
norwegian refugee council thanks so much
for your time
thank you
let's return now to the weather across
the uk with forecasters predicting
thunder lightning and flooding as the
recent dry spell comes to an end
let's bring in one of the experts met
office meteorologist claire nausea
claire lovely to see you this morning um
i suppose given given how much we have
all been performing rain dances in our
back gardens we many people will be
welcoming the weather but
i mean it could be pretty grim
yes certainly and when we're looking at
thunderstorms to be honest it's the
wrong kind of rain which we need for the
ground particularly across central and
eastern areas of england where we've
seen the land so parched over this
summer it's been a very dry year so far
and what we're looking for is sort of
continuous rain
moderate rain rather than this
incredibly intense burst which currently
is moving up across more southern areas
of england so we're not out of the woods
yet neil and we've seen
heavy rain last night thunder and
lightning not only across england and
wales some heavy rain across eastern
scotland where there's a rain warning
until 10 a.m this morning and ireland
also the last few days seeing some
biblical downpours
claire just explain why this this rain
this rain as as previously mentioned
people have been almost praying for why
it isn't just settling straight into the
ground and getting getting sucked up by
these well the the soil that hasn't seen
a drop of it for weeks
well right now the soil is very thin but
also very hard and the rain just bounces
off it to be honest neil it doesn't
absorb it so there's no mechanism to
actually bringing that moisture which
allows the soil just to be moist which
is what we see most of the year across
the uk so these hard arched lands are
just seeing this rain run off and that's
when we've seen flooding localized
flooding and and that's going to be the
case again today as these thunderstorms
march their way northwards and develop
in situ across england and wales there's
a warning out right the way through
today across england and wales
just something that appeared in one of
the newspapers this morning i think i
think in the mail in fact um
they were saying that the met office
have told households to pack grab bags
and that's something i know from you
know foreign travel where generally
we're going off to get shot at but what
they're talking about is that grant what
apparently you're talking about is grab
bags containing mobile phones insurance
documents emergency cash i mean is that
is it really that bad
well i've experienced it myself here in
cheshire before where we've seen really
intense heavy rain over a short period
of time and my garden hasn't been able
to cope with it and the waters were
running high
so high actually that they were just
seeping into my back door and that's
pretty much the situation the metal
office is talking about we're talking
about intense rain which over just a
couple of hours we could see up to 50
millimeters in places and that really
has an impact on the ground because it
can't absorb the the rain and it has to
go somewhere so for low-lying properties
which perhaps have been built on a flood
plain yes you know there is a risk of
flooding in properties get that yet all
your documents whether it's you know
your mobile phone your passport etc all
those things you don't want to be
damaged by flood water and make sure
they're ready to go or on a higher level
of your house
are we at the point clear of being able
to say with with a degree of certainty
that this is the new normal that this is
what we all have to start getting used
to
yes and in fact for the last decade
we've seen this more and more so
through the summer months the weather is
turning hotter we know that from this
year in the last 10 years if not longer
but not only that when we do see rain
it's short intense bursts
warm air hot air can absorb more
moisture and that is one of the
precursors for thunderstorms and that's
exactly what we've seen over the last 24
hours or so so yes climate trends
suggest that even though our summers are
going to be drier and hotter when you do
see the rain it's going to be more
intense
and clear just just finally people
watching this who want to find out just
the latest information when if they want
to know what weather warnings are in
place where do we head apart from this
guy website obviously of course i met up
his website but actually what i use
every day and this is one of my key
things is the phone it's the met office
um weather app it's absolutely brilliant
it's got envision forecasts so you can
listen to the forecast but also radar so
the current situation the distribution
of those thunderstorms and that rain and
also the forecast of that rainfall over
the next 36 hours so it's a really good
tool to use particularly if you're
traveling over the next few days
clear great to talk to you take care in
the reigns
now it is round seven in the tory
leadership hostings tonight
uh is livel's risk trust and rishi sumac
face party members in perth for the one
and only trip to scotland with exactly
three weeks until one of them enters
number 10 and let's take a look at the
state of the race with opinions head of
political polling chris curtis chris
lovely to see you um let's get straight
into voting intentions then uh when
we're taking a look at liz soon at rishi
tsunak versus liz truss
well i mean it's it's pretty
straightforward isn't it i mean she's
got it in the bag that's not close um so
this is our latest poll from the weekend
we interviewed little over 500
conservative party members and and yeah
22 point lead for liz trust that lead
has if anything just been growing ever
since we had these final two candidates
i don't know 10 years ago it feels like
when it was this race originally started
um uh so yes i mean at this point we're
starting to feel fairly confident
um if not very confident uh that liz
truss is going to be prime minister in
september i mean before we before we
move on to the next bit of data i'm
speaking to peter kellner of course i'm
sure you know very very very very know
very well exactly um and he said look
when i said like is there any chance
that you could get this one wrong that
you know that we are a distance away
three weeks still for things to change i
mean if if you did get it wrong the
polling industry he said would be would
have to really look inwards on this one
yeah i mean look i'm a lot less
confident in party members polling than
i am in our general election polling
there's loads of there's loads more ways
that it can be inaccurate we don't know
um the demographic profile of
conservative party members because the
conservative party doesn't release it
it's very hard to poll these people
because there aren't that many of them
and there's also a lot of them that are
very very old and therefore less likely
to take part in polls so there is a lot
more scope foreign conservative party
members polling but this kind of lead is
not the kind of lead that's overcome
usually
by a small polling error now when i'm
watching our political correspondence
travelling the country going to all of
these hustings whenever they pitch up at
them the mantra from the members that
they speak to appears to be i haven't
decided yet i'm going to make my mind up
i mean how true is it that that people
are
waiting until they see the candidates
face to face or waiting until the last
possible moment to make the decision
well our latest stage rules say from
this poll uh shows that well this has
taken over the course of the last week
these numbers will probably have changed
quite dramatically since then but even
on the numbers that we had here you know
29 had already voted and then an
additional um when nearly half had said
that well i haven't voted and almost
getting around to it but we've
completely made up our mind so there's
very few people left over at the end
that are still swayable based on on what
they're seeing in this contest now
people turning up and going and seeing
the hustings might be slightly more
likely to be undecided and looking for
something to help make up their mind but
actually the data at this stage says
that most members um uh pretty much made
a decision about how they're going to
vote so even if i don't know rishi soon
axe say where to you know nick circus
darma's idea for for sorting out the
energy it came forward with something
big genuinely a kind of an eye-catching
policy
might not have much of a shift in the
position well i'm not sure that's the
kind of thing that would best appeal to
conservative party members
regardless i mean look theoretically if
you take everybody who says that they're
going to vote for rishi sunak and
everybody who says that they might
change their mind and you add those two
groups together you do get to a number
uh that is higher than liz's truck liz
trust's number but i think it's very
unlikely um that that's the the outcome
that we're heading for so in terms of
the issues what is it that is swaying
people uh to one another yeah so one of
the things we did on this poll was we
asked people who were voting for the two
candidates what the main reasons were
that they were doing so this is the uh
the top two reasons why people are
voting for rishi sunek ultimately that
top one over there better at managing
the economy he's been putting forward
this
almost cameron-esque
fiscal responsibility is important we
have to be grown-ups we have to care
about the public finances we have to
care about balancing just to be clear
this does not mean that 10 of party
members believe that rishi sunak is
intelligent that's just their stated 10
percent yeah of those who are voting for
them yeah what we're doing is we're
asking people who are voting for him
what's the main reason the minority of
members who are voting finn what's the
main reason that you're doing so and
these are the top two it is to do with
you know the people the minority who are
supporting them him they're being driven
by this idea that he's the grown-up who
can manage the economy best um and i
think do we have time just to have a
quick look at the last no we don't
we do just here we go liz trust
again you know the loyalty to johnson is
an interesting one yes i mean if it's a
theme that runs across all three of
these ultimately the reason the majority
of members are voting for liz trust is
because they don't trust uh rishi sunax
so much particularly the fact that he
resigned from uh boris johnson's cabinet
in a way that liz trust didn't
um so three weeks to go things could
still shift in
in some ways but but as things stand if
you're a betting man i mean there's only
one place that people are putting the
money at the moment isn't it the
overwhelming likelihood is that liz
trusts is going to be giving that
conference speech to the conservatives
this september or tiger chris lovely to
talk to you and of course if you get it
wrong we'll get you back on to explain
it thanks very much indeed
now let's take you through some of the
pictures of the day and as we've been
discussing rain finally falling in some
parts of the united kingdom well this
start photo it was taken at a part in
warwick showing the difference
between on this side the natural parched
grass
and the artificial grass over there on
the right
here's another interesting picture
you'll already seen if you've been
watching since the top of the air
removal vans have been seen in dining
street as boris johnson prepares to
leave number 10 in just under three
weeks time when either liz truss or
rishi sunak will be taking office at
boris johnson currently on holiday with
his family in greece but a spokesman
said he'll return this weekend
now the uk's only outdoor skydive
machine opens for the first time to the
public today not for me some thrill
seekers like 13 year old adam carter
pictured here
got the chance to experience the
attraction early it is part of hang
loose adventure in kent which also
boasts a 46 meter drop swing and
england's longest zip wire
now the london premiere for house of the
dragon was last night
some of the casts turning up the stars
of the show including paddy considine
who you just saw there matt smith also a
big role in it they all walked the red
carpet ahead of the release of the first
episode next week to celebrate the
series launch an iron throne was placed
at leicester square for the cast and
indeed the general public to pose with
we will have much much more on that
breaking news around people's wages and
of course the threat of thunderstorms
across the uk after this
you